fox news reporter peter ducey is back in
the white house press briefing room
and is simply determined to end up
humiliating himself at absolutely every
opportunity now i want to be really
clear here because
every time we talk about stuff like this
i get emails david how are you now
just accepting everything that the white
house press secretary no no no no
every white house press secretary
distorts answers selectively
flame frames everything that an
administration does in the best possible
light this is their job
that being said there is a real
difference when gensake
replaced kaylee mcinanni when joe biden
became president and donald trump left
there was a significant change which was
that at least in principle the briefings
became about substance
and most reporters were able to start
asking
mostly substantive questions you still
get
pr answers that's the role of a press
secretary i'm not denying that
fox news's peter ducey is a notable
exception to most
reporters are trying to ask substantive
questions he's been focused
from day one on asking bizarre leading
loaded
inaccurate and even childless questions
constantly trying to trap
gensake and even joe biden sometimes in
gotcha type situations and peter ducey
did the exact same thing on friday
that's the most recent press briefing
uh as as of right now i think there is
one scheduled for a little bit later
today
and jen saki was having absolutely none
of it
uh peter ducey here is trying to jump
all over a report
that the u.s surgeon general's office
put out which is that there is a small
number of
primary disseminators of covid and
vaccine disinformation on social media
12 people in fact
we've known for some time that a huge
portion of the anti-vaxx
disinformation originates from a small
number of accounts
they've been tracking vaccine
disinformation at the surgeon general's
level
and peter ducey frames it as a personal
targeted spying campaign
and uh here is how that exchange went
take a listen to this
okay so these 12 people who you have on
a list
12 individuals do they even this idea of
a list as nefarious how else do you
categorize things
instead of a list you have a what by
definition
if you if you're aware of 12 people it's
colloquially a list but he's even trying
to weaponize
list so then later right wingers can say
this is a mccarthyite
list of some kind okay did somebody at
the surgeon general's office
is going through their profile i'm happy
to get you the citation of where that
comes from there's no secret list
i will tell you that these are people
who are sharing information
on public platforms on facebook
information that is traveling
is inaccurate our biggest concern here
and i frankly think it should be
your biggest concern is the number of
people who are dying around the country
because
that's not his biggest concern john no
that's it's it's just not
getting misinformation that is leading
them to not take a vaccine
young people old people kids children
this is all being a lot of them are
being impacted by misinformation
though i think for a lot of people on
facebook is that now this is big brother
watching you they're more concerned
about that than people dying
right now most people on facebook are
saying why is the anti-vaccine stuff
even being allowed on facebook
true because of a pandemic where
misinformation is traveling on social
media platforms
that feels unlikely to me if you have
the data to back that up i'm happy to
discuss it
so this is quite well handled it's not
just
some gensake victory party gensake
is a mouthpiece for the administration
this is her job it's no special virtue
but she's doing a good job of pointing
out hold on the vaccine disinformation
leads to death
that should be the primary concern 99
plus percent of hospitalizations are
unvaccinated
99.2 percent of the deaths last month
were unvaccinated
and in comes steve ducey again and this
is how you craft
narrative to later repeat on fox news
announcement from yesterday for how long
has the administration been spying
on people's facebook profiles looking
for vaccine
misinformation well that was quite a
loaded and inaccurate question
um which i would refute well peter first
of all as you know we're
we're in a regular touch with with a
range of media outlets
as as let me finish as we are
as he's just like an insufferable little
kid we are
in regular touch with social media
platforms
this is publicly uh open information
people sharing
information online just as you are all
reporting
information on your news stations okay
announcement from yesterday so um
but by the way just to be thorough very
well sourced
this gensake is communicating
about research that found 12 people are
behind
a huge amount of the vaccine hoax
information disinformation on social
media okay
there's a very good npr article about it
from a couple months ago
it's been continued to to be looked at
researchers found 12 people are
responsible for the bulk
of the misleading claims and outright
lies about covet vaccines that
proliferate on facebook instagram and
twitter
the disinformation doesn't produce 65
percent of the shares
of anti-vaccine misinformation on social
media platforms so
there's no doubt about the data but
the concern with imaginary spying when
what we're talking about
is the enforcement of terms of service
and a study of where this stuff is
coming from
the priorities are completely backwards
and steve
steve peter ducey steve ducey's son
continuing to just make a fool out of
himself but
the problem is a lot of the trump
supporters don't see it this way
you might say a normal person would see
this and they would say hold on a second
99 of the hospitalized are unvaccinated
99 of the deaths are unvaccinated now
if you perpetuate anti-vax
disinformation which prevents people
from getting vaccinated
you're essentially leading to people's
deaths that's
incredibly serious and absolutely
immoral the focus should be on stopping
that
but no it's about the surgeon general's
office quote spying
and unfortunately it works it works on
the fox news audience it works on
the legacy rush limbaugh audience that
is now kind of fragmented in listening
to different shows
uh so completely missing the plot and
peter ducey continuing to make a fool
out of himself on a regular basis
if you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much i
love
my helix mattress well i was really
excited to hear that helix has launched
a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you 20 off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put
in my living room at home it's now my
favorite piece of furniture
in the house it took me just minutes to
set it up it's
solidly built it's huge it's roomy
it has a modern minimalist design which
i love but it's also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality it has become the
focal point of my living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it and the best part is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now
and get 20 off your entire order when
you get there by going to
all form dot com slash pacman i've also
put the link right underneath this video